that's not Minaj's coming in what's
going on man you're happening that's
what's happened really it's why now
we're live no I was just you think I'd
be that flattering like off the air like
I'm just like yeah man you're happening
like hilarious
yeah what's going on man I'm I'm just
coming in and doing this show man we
debut on Sunday I'm not sleeping and you
know just getting the word out just
getting the word out yeah now this is a
how are you feeling about on a couple of
levels Patriot Act is of course the show
on Netflix yes your show yes number one
you leave the comfort of The Daily Show
oh man
and it was a nice gig right and you
leave that to do your own thing where
it's you're responsible for right on The
Daily Show he's got a tripping dude
right you get it all your concentration
into your bit support Michael right
right now you're taking the MJ spot
which is a tough spot to be in and
you're doing it on Netflix where they've
attempted yes but it hasn't really they
haven't clicked in with what is the
recipe for topical success why do you
think that is for a show I think because
people are just like Netflix conditions
people to watch it a certain way yes and
I think people end up confused when it's
like we well where's the rest of them I
just watched 30 of them right now but
then what why do you think it worked
say on HBO like when you when you go to
HBO go well I think because people are
so used to I think it's just the
conditioning right like HBO condition
people yeah that this is traditional TV
even though it's an app you know what
HBO is you can binge it in you can write
every week in episode comes out I'll
watch the old ones and binge but
Westworld comes on and every week John
Oliver comes on every week yeah so I
think I may be Netflix just needs to do
it enough times maybe your maybe now is
the perfect time I think I think look
man I also feel very lucky they gave me
run run wait room you know we have a big
order right so it's like we have time
here they got 32 episodes yeah which is
about you know it's gonna take us right
up to you know up to 2020 so that's a
yeah that's a year and change a year and
change right which is good
that's huge we get good yes I don't
think they've done that before thirty
now they did you know yeah yeah we had
you know it was a good it was a good
situation yeah that's a show of faith
like that's got to make you feel
confident in like okay
Netflix has my back on this like
we both have the vision for this thing
that should be successful yeah I mean
and we put together proof of concept so
before I even we even shopped it was
like hey this is what the show looks
like so you made an episode of
hypothetical show correct you can touch
it you can feel it you can just hit play
here's the Vimeo link hit play boom boom
and they probably thought to anybody
that like wants this enough and has
enough of a concept in their head that
they're actually just gonna go and make
one yeah we can trust them to do the
work that's required yes to do a show
yeah and I think I think look I also
have a very unique fan base mm-hmm that
has not has been has not really been
tapped into and what is what's the fan
base I think it's just really young
people with varying shades of melanin
who share my identity share sort of like
my POV uh-huh that you don't see a lot
of yes and I think I mean you you
probably know this come in coming in the
radio and podcasting space is you you
have you bring your sort of legion of
fans definitely and that's that's
important yeah and it's not sort of like
hey there's this new face and we have to
sort of build it up and I sort of have
an existing group of people that I think
are really really rabid and want to see
me take these swings and take talk about
some of these topics that don't get
talked about a lot in the news and we
were talking about like like megan kelly
and how her ultimate screw-up wasn't
about black face it was trying to do
something that was completely foreign to
her built-in audience wise should feel
like you're pretty smart in the sense
that you're like I'm gonna go off and do
this new show that's just my show but
yeah stuff that people love on the daily
show the spirit of that yes it's still
you know intertwined yeah with the
storytelling elements of what I did and
a special all of that stuff but you know
we've graduated we're doing highbrow
cultural commentary political commentary
so it's like the merger of all these
things now do you sit and go like okay
we need to figure out where the balance
is between funny and political and
preachy and this and that because you
know there's as much as there's an
audience that isn't spoken for there's a
huge audience that like the minute you
show up at the Correspondents Dinner I'm
sure you made fans and you made new
people that you made enemies right yeah
yeah that's where people are right now
yeah look you know this man for what we
do
indifference or hatred is hey I'm out
I'm not I'm not trying to speak to
either of those two people of just
people who are just like yeah I'm not
interested in in a political satire show
I don't want I don't want to watch that
right I was never gonna get those people
or people who hate me who were just like
dude I hate his hair I hate his I
profess I hate everything about this guy
right
dislike he seems happy seems like Indian
boyband looking right you know they see
Ryan Seacrest looking dude is up here
talking to hear it right I'm never gonna
convince that person to want to see the
show this is about people who are like
oh yeah finally right so this is more
what you have in mind is like this is
almost like what you would would want to
see what I would want to see right and
then as an artist you're just like put
out the stuff that you feel needs to be
said or exist in the world that's it I
was listening to you on Bill Simmons
podcast and you said something
interesting that uh that you said that
the Correspondents Dinner you thought
was like a great gig one of the best
gigs and comedy period undeniable no
questions asked which is wild because
like most people would not agree with
that I think people who have done it
like it seems stressful it seems like
it's a it's an audience that is not your
audience necessarily uh you know it's it
seems like a terrible environment for
comedy yeah but you also have to
understand the variables everyone at
home is watching
so you're thinking not just at the
audience in the room why would you write
I think a lot of comics why would you be
that short-sighted well I think a lot of
comics are you know they get their
conditioning on the stage and even when
they're did like they think about the
people in the room Sam please explain
this to me yeah you get to how often in
what other country in the world do you
get to make fun of the most powerful
people to their face point at them and
go yeah you look like this what
technically Trump wasn't there so you
didn't get to do it right to his face
I mean but you're talking about what he
saw you're talking about all the people
that disseminate not only the media
coverage yes but also like
administrative people in the
administration when you can do a
five-minute bid on USA Today and the
people from USA Today are sitting there
going like hundred percent come on yeah
that's
edible that syncretism I don't know what
to tell you man
with that I am the world is watching
yeah and let's let's add layer number
three there's no physical consequences
that happened to you coming out of that
if anything benefits you 1000% real we
we know what what happened this past
week with the killing of journalist
Jamal khashoggi of course you don't have
to worry that's a privilege man right
right I think a lot of American comics
don't understand that yeah that's what I
want do you said that's the perspective
I want to add to the show look at the
whole world by the way Netflix goes to
190 countries like you're celebrating
the fact like not only are we doing half
the show is celebrating that we're doing
it Yeah right I think it's cool who
someone who looks like me people have
certain assumptions about maybe I this
is what I love America for so when did
you lock into this is who I am I'm
confident in Who I am I'm gonna deliver
this message to this audience like I'm
sure in the beginning you're just trying
to appeal to people right right I think
that that's a comment
totally tow median thing love I want
appeal I want laughs yeah you're just
like Facebook's crazy right exactly so
what yeah it's a while hasn't that broad
net yeah at what point do you go I Know
Who I am I know what I'm doing yeah I
mean you start to see who you really
love mm-hmm like when you start you
start understanding the musicians that
you really love the movies that you
really love what makes them special
there are anomalies they're really
really good at they're one of one you
know yeah feel special they don't feel
like anything else and then you start
what do you start so you get to a point
where you're like wait this is what I'm
becoming like this is my goal to become
in there I remember struggled with it
for a long time and people can look at
my old stand-up clips and be like yeah
he's not that good because yeah I was
I'm just trying to relate to everybody
and look some people will look at my
stuff now and be like I still don't
think it's very good and you're not
you're 100% entitled to your opinion but
but I'm doing me and I think I think
this is I'm I'm I'm starting to feel you
know now now doing comedy now for 14
years feeling I'm now exploring this
very interesting space yeah and I'm
excited by that
and it's interesting cuz you went to
school for political science right so
you're actually getting to use
yes in what you do yes you know which is
interesting because I went to school for
sociology I use any other conversation
about how college is a racket by the way
like Poli Sci it's sixty units in like
those books I could have just gotten on
amazon.com right and just in read write
four chapters because that's what I
ended up doing Riedel right exactly yeah
and you know whether you write a paper
or not you've come on let's be really
attain the same amount of yeah yeah but
if you like you talk to someone like
Stephen Colbert who's like a a Jedi
Master of rhetoric logic the English
language he's a he's a voracious reader
it's great like you're like oh that's
why you're one of the greatest of all
time and what you do yes because yeah
because no I'm talking about take
performance to the side I'm talking
about brain power right how many guys do
you know who've been like hey have you
read this book on logic and rhetoric
like currently uh-huh not a lot no of
course not not a lot there's a lot of
scrolling going on yeah I mean not a lot
of like like what's the blurb on it yeah
I read it on the skin yes guy like
you'll see in interviews is my favorite
thing you'll do you'll be like in an
interview to be like you know Toya you
know it'll be like you know to Aristotle
once said I'm like how did you how would
you possibly know what Aristotle ever
said how did you know that how did you
just have that yeah one of my favorite
Tolstoy quotes is this I'm like what
yeah and you'll do that casually in
conversation to it's incredible yeah and
you're like I thought as comedians all
we need to be responsible for was the
most creative way to talk about our
penises and you're sitting here raising
the bar to this level correct whatever
but it's something I aspire to does that
both of those to be able to wield both
of those swords the performance side and
the intellectual side so what what do
the the did you talk to Jon Oliver you
talked to Stephen Colbert you talked to
I know you know Jon Stewart you the last
guy that yeah Stewart that came on your
steward for the show yeah like do you
talk to those guys in preparing for this
I mean the universal thing but they've
all they've all told me is that they're
like you have to make it uniquely your
own mm-hmm you know I think that's why
John Oliver is so successful yeah it's
because like he's who knows exactly what
he's really good at yeah he knows what
he wants to do when he's yeah
I think I think John Oliver is like this
great example of a guy and you know
obviously haven't seen your show yet cuz
it premieres ya Sunday but he's a guy
that I think regardless of how you feel
politically you can watch his show and
be entertained and enjoy it and possibly
learn like John Oliver's show can sway
an opinion I think so I think so
I mean I've watched it you know going
like you disagree with them you disagree
with this position and it changes your
opinion I or or I'll go like you I'd
you're indifferent about the about the
thing wrong you're like FIFA or like I
feel that I'll share a CNN version of
the opinion and I'll go like CNN just
doing when CNN always does I can't I
can't put up with this anymore
John Oliver's talking about the same
thing yes and I good what's all what's
John Oliver saying now like when he did
the whole like Trump Trump show yet I'm
like I've heard the Trump criticisms
like I don't need somebody bring it down
for a half hour and then I turn it on
and I'm like this is amazing - yeah like
this is really good he's incredible and
because there's like work put into it
yeah you can tell yeah you can tell and
I've heard you talk about how much work
is being put into you're insane yeah
it's insane hopefully it connects like
that's the thing I realize that you have
no control over mm-hmm it's like will it
will it connect right I think the the
this the good thing I feel is I there's
times where I feel really scared of the
things I'm saying I'm like man should I
be saying this I see that make sense
yeah totally that make sense
and you like that should I yeah I'm
poking certain bears that don't get
poked you like you know these things
that you're saying this is very they're
very real right there's a lot of
international reporting and evidence on
these things
but people don't poke these bears often
times we've been political for a long
time have you done anything that like
has come back at you in a way where
you're like I didn't think this level of
person would care I mean like you're
always gonna get there's blips yes blips
so after the correspondence center you
get blips right right you know you are
making fun of the President and writing
all that stuff so yeah and is that's
like after you do the Correspondents
Dinner does it surprise you that the
response that you're getting isn't
necessarily just comedy response it's
like real response like you know on a
political level yeah but I knew I I
didn't you know you never you don't know
what the next day will be like you're
just you're again this this is what
with wisdom and wisdom comes from
experience I hadn't experienced that
being on the other side of that right
but you know the older Jedi they tell
you they let you know what happens yeah
you're going to be eye of the storm and
you know you're poking the Barrens
there's gonna be there's gonna be
repercussions this is gonna happen how
did you feel when you find out Trump
wasn't gonna be there uh when I found
out that he wasn't gonna be there I was
like no duh he's not gonna come the Year
the year that I that I did it the the
gig was very radioactive remember his
first year in office right so him not
attending was the first time a president
had an attendance since Reagan got shot
uh-huh right and Reagan the reason he
didn't attend was because shot yeah boy
did he put a bullet right
he still sent a message in like hey I
support the event I support the press
all that stuff
so then people will like me should we do
the here yeah eventually not it was this
whole controversy then a bunch of
celebrities a bunch of organizations
were pulling out then I did this is an
important thing I did my research what
is the event about
oh it's celebrating freedom of speech
it's give scholarships to young
journalists yeah I should support this
event
and also like people around the world
watch this event it's important was
there any part of you that like as toxic
as it had gotten and as it still is
getting like there are a lot of people
yeah that have just decided there is no
humor to be had in this uh-huh you know
what I mean and we don't eat we don't
want anything associated with it this is
horrible if we're talking about what's
going on right now it should be an
outrage and and protest and blah blah
blah like there is no humor in this does
that has that ever given you pause of
being like oh are they right should we
not or do you realize like no this is
this is how we tackle this uh III think
you the the challenge of great stand-up
comedy is being able to walk that line
right and I remember I remember seeing
John respond to Sandy Hook and I've seen
John also fight for the Zadroga bill
stuff like that right to get 911 first
responders coverage and in health care
right
I've seen the choices he's made how he's
moved and operated to say what is the
ultimate destination of what I want to
achieve I want people to understand this
mm-hmm I want our first responders to
bill get medical care all right this is
how I have to
line my argument up you can napalm the
room right and do that but I've seen him
construct the argument so perfectly and
thread that needle like how did he not
get intercepted how did he throw that
pass right that is what I aspire to do
that to me is the genius right on when
comedies done at that such a high level
that you people you you get you get
multiple results number one people like
wow he said that with so much clarity
number two people who didn't know about
the issue or like holy [ __ ] how did I
not know that
and number three people who even
disagree with you and this is the next
level part mm-hmm they either turn or
they go I disagree with you but I
respect your position right right which
is kind of like we're talking about John
Oliver and the response that I had when
it's like when I'm like no I I remember
yeah I respect it I'm gonna watch the
show like yeah yeah the highest
compliment right totally um when you're
working for the Daily Show right you're
doing these interviews in the bits like
right generally speaking the people
you're interviewing are not in on
exactly what's going on sure
so do you have what level of it is
written in advance because I feel like a
lot of these sort of the comedy in the
bits that you're doing right are written
around the responses that you get in
your interview yeah you have to be good
at improv but you have to come in with
the take right so you come in with the
take and then you kind of in your head
formulate where this is gonna go based
on those interviews and give the
responses that you're gonna correct you
have to be good at improv in writing
yeah because I see like come on look
there's a difference look go to youtube
right now and look at the difference
between someone with a random youtube
channel yeah in Jordan Klepper at a
trump rally uh-huh there is it is not
you're like that is a professional right
and this is a dude with an SLR and his
friend yeah yeah because I see it and
I'm rushing people I go like I can't
like the end it's like the little facial
expressions and I'm like oh I think that
was edited and in post but then they do
the they take the shot with both of you
in it or something and I'm like if some
of these raw tapes and and it's like
this is one of the cool things of
working at the Daily Show I would see
old tapes of Steve Carell at Helm's we
have riggles Stephen Colbert Samantha
bee I think I've said this OP of clapper
is one of the best people in the field
he's
so you like I don't mean to be super
Indian here but if you if your brain is
an operating system right he's the
processor that he has in his head is
insane uh-huh his ability to respond so
quick I've never seen anything like it
in my life
so have you ever been doing an interview
with somebody for a story or whatever
where you're going like this isn't quite
as ridiculous as I thought it was yeah
like where it's like wait a minute I
don't even know he says die all the time
really so you're like you pieces get
killed all the time and it comes from
like I'm interviewing this person and I
don't really think that there's that
much to me it's not working or it's not
there this isn't going anywhere right
the person doesn't want to participate
anymore
yeah have you dealt with you know this
thing needs to be mocked like we have to
mock this yes but I like that person
that I was talking to correct it sucks
like I kind of gotta humiliate this
person yes you've been there yeah I like
Wolf Blitzer but I got to make fun of
them right it's your job yeah I like him
he's a very sweet person and people in
journalism really respected me he's a
very sweet person right but he's also
Wolf Blitzer you're not you know how
much choice here yeah yeah and look like
I'm a I love that I love that I chalk it
up to the game like that is that is the
ultimate thing that I respect about
comedy if you're a public figure
everybody on either side of the aisle is
open to criticism and that's great
myself included have you found that a
Wolf Blitzer for instance yes subscribes
to the same theory he was a very good
sport about it he was and I respect that
have you dealt with people who are not
good sports about it uh yes I can't
remember anyone offhand but yes yeah
people have been like you shouldn't have
done that or I'm offended or all that
stuff yeah are you even in the beginning
were you sensitive about that stuff
meaning if somebody goes like yeah you
really [ __ ] up my life by doing that I
hope you enjoyed that are you going like
I don't know if I should have the
targets I'm picking they got a lot of
power and influence man they have a lot
of influence it's not like you're
punching
I really don't pick on people go through
my Twitter I don't beef with people on
Twitter right there's people that come
after me but I'm just like I this poor
guy with an egg avatar I'm not gonna go
after him right he's got two followers
he's like whoever he is I'm like look I
maybe maybe it's like I'm sensitive I
don't know I'm just like dude I know I
know I sometimes I see those comments
and I remember like even when I was like
working at Office Max there was a like
one of my first jobs there was like a
guy who would like
write comments on chat forums and stuff
like that and I'm like this guy's really
sad yeah you know what I mean there was
that part of me that's like like you
don't want to bash this guy because it's
like he's know and they'll write
paragraphs so you can read YouTube
comments on me this guy's pathetic I
hate him he's bubble not funny he's
trying too hard all that stuff you read
them of course you do yes you go into
spirals of self-loathing uhm the
scariest parts but when they there
oddly accurate they hit you with
something that you already think you
knew that yourself that you hope no one
else noticed they're like hey one of his
eyes is bigger than the other and you're
like [ __ ] how do you shake it off well I
don't know man it's it's one of those
things where it like the internet
matters it does matter there's a real
life effects to it but then it also
doesn't matter
right because you both of those you have
to understand both of those things at
once yeah cuz there are people that
think this is the end-all be-all
yes it was set on the internet and like
your life is over now yeah it isn't
that's it I mean that's a gross
overstating yeah and you also just have
to realize you're just like you hey like
don't think about this like you're in
middle school remember out in middle
school you're like I want everyone to
like me it's just not possible right
it's not cool and when you have a bill
but like I walk to work every morning
right know and I see your face as I'm
walking along like hey I'm interviewing
that guy in two weeks yeah I'm
interviewing that guy in right and then
one week and I like it like you just
everybody right and when you had that
going on it's like yeah people you
you're giving people the right to meal
Brendan Holograms this is a great Neal
Brennan bit I'm not doing it justice but
you know he's like he's like even
Beethoven there's certain songs like on
YouTube it's like you know that done
don't know that that iconic mm-hmm in
arguably one of the greatest pieces of
art created writer has 223 Meggitt comes
down like this like yeah
so Mona Lisa right you know Sistine
Chapel
thumbs down ugly not so I'm just like
what are we gonna do here right yeah
right it is what it is yeah this is
you're putting content out there yeah
so do you just consume content
constantly because you know the more I
kind of watch your interviews to read
about
you or whatever it seems like you're
completely up-to-date on the sports
world yes completely up-to-date on the
politics war yes you have a pop-culture
take correct like do you just feel like
it's your job to just be constantly
consuming and be constantly aware of
everything that's going on I like I like
seeing culture and where it's at right
and talking to people about it and even
if I'm not watching every TV show
talking to people about the issues
talking to people about what moves the
needle in their life I want to add value
to people's lives man I mean and I know
that sounds corny I mean that honestly
right when I watch people I'll watch
people on the subway I'll watch people
at the airport I'll watch the way
they're scrolling I'll watch the way the
white headphones are in I'll watch the
way people push their babies through the
streets of New York they're moving their
babies on their phone like I'll watch
that and I'll go okay well if someone's
on their phone is there something I can
give them that will add value to their
life or perspective or something good
mm-hmm
do you know what I mean yeah yes there's
a lot of I don't I just know what an
[ __ ] yes yes you can there's a lot of
[ __ ] out there yes there's a lot of
just garbage just being thrown into your
into your mind if I can add something of
value that's what I'm trying to do and
so I try to talk to people about all
that stuff to be like what are you
thinking about and then I really think
about it what can I add to the
conversation it's gonna add something to
your life so how do you filter out when
you're consuming your content how do you
filter out what is the [ __ ] and what
is like this actually has a value for me
to have in my brain well I I try to read
nutrition dense content I see that make
sense yeah your times the Atlantic the
Economist I watched a 90 day fiancé it's
like two hours yeah yeah of coming up
next
don't get me wrong like if someone's
just like you need to watch queer eye or
the Great British Bake Off okay
I'll taste it but you'll take a look
yeah I gotta watch a whole season but I
have a baby have a wife yeah and I'm
doing the show but yeah I will give it I
will watch it and I get and by the way I
appreciate both ends of the spectrum I
totally get why people are just like
dude I want to think about politics I
don't give a [ __ ] like right I live in
Plano Texas
I go to Mike that I go to for my job in
Dallas I Drive to play know I have my
did it I have my kids I got that I don't
want to hear your nonsense I like III
empathize with those people I'm on
whatsapp threads with like my friends
come in Sacramento like I really try to
think about people's lives so do you try
to shape what you're doing now to fit
your audience obviously that also does
kind of have political fatigue that
doesn't want to be like told how bad the
world is yeah you know what I mean like
shape it for an audience that's like
correct you know I want to watch
something that's entertaining correct
yeah correct
but by the women people are just like
things are too dark are you kidding me
people watch murder documentaries on
Netflix
yeah people getting murdered
unfortunately Norton's not here but he
just like only two weeks ago said that
he was giving up watching cartel
beheading videos like Jim's another
beast oh yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah
like so for me I'm just like I I don't I
don't completely believe that
proposition I believe people are
interested in great stories ya can use
story tell do you get to that's that's
the challenge I give myself so you've
never gotten to a place where you're
like [ __ ] this I'm just gonna do a
sports show I just talk about school
dude I fantasize about this all the time
yes yeah I tell Jen this all the time
like I'm like this all just fails I
could just be one of those like I could
be one of those hosts on one of those
cooking shows that's it like the chew
easy I'm like today we're gonna make my
mom's chicken tikka masala
they're like spicy and that's it but you
know what happens with those people
they're all stressed out because they're
all fighting each other but are you
stressed out this is a great I'm
stressed out all the time why though
that's a great gig because the gig is is
I'm very worried that people are gonna
find out like there is no reason to pay
that guy yeah to just talk about stuff
huh every day
everybody talks about stuff every day
yeah why would we pay him to just sit
here and talk about as you're compelling
and interesting you'd you know that's a
whole argument that you'd have to win
yeah the whole argument that you'd have
to win I mean you know I go up and down
I think like anybody else like I'll go
one minute I'll have all the ego in the
world of being like I've gotten really
good at this I've got I've really
figured this out uh-huh and then the
next day I mean that's I guess that's
part of doing a show every day yeah the
next day it's like what the [ __ ] am i
doing who do you think is the greatest
interviewer all-time your craft who's
the greatest interviewer of all time it
makes you go wow they're really amazing
at their craft well I mean the
this interview just for you it's your
personal choice your your NBA alt you
know all-nba first team you know I like
like I like Letterman a lot yeah in the
sense that he wouldn't he would get
things out of people yeah but it
wouldn't be like let's stop everything
and let's drag something out of your
soul like relax we all know right when
we're watching an interview that even if
somebody is being very revealing even if
they go I forgot I was in an interview
he didn't forget like we know that we're
all like agreeing to something here
Letterman would just do such a good job
of bringing people into his world yeah
and then trying to shape it for the
audience like if it's Paris Hilton he
would know that his audience thinks that
Paris Hilton is just vapid yeah and when
she started being vapid like okay let's
explore this because I know what the
audience is thinking so I've always
liked stuff like that
okay you know what about you I haven't
thought about that that's also asking
you guys know that this is your this is
like your craft right yeah yeah stuff
like that I mean I like I like I like
when people I've always thought like
Howard Stern for example that was the
easy one for best interviewer yeah but
I've always I think what Howard Stern is
the best at is making his personal life
interesting hmm like getting me to a
place in the car where like he's talking
about he'll I remember for some reason
he would do like he's just talking for
20 minutes about how yeah you know he
went to church to pray for something but
he doesn't really want to talk about
what he was praying for but he's just
talking about it right all right
and like I'm so compelled that's awesome
I'm not turning off the radio I want to
know what's going on in a storytelling
that's very telling
storytelling is what I like yeah yeah
but but the framework of it is like
you're talking my religion don't do that
story time you got to be a great
storyteller
yeah yeah that's bright and that's yeah
that's what you're doing with politics
right I'm trying to it's like you know
just just turn it into a story correct
it blew the character yeah yeah great